[Musik]
die schöne heile welt der amazon
kurierfahrer fröhlich und gut gelaunt so
wirbt der versandriese
erfurt vor dem amazon verteilzentrum
rauschen jeden morgen hunderte
kleintransporter an die fahrer
überwiegend osteuropäer die meisten sind
angestellt bei subunternehmen die für
den amerikanischen konzern pakete
ausfahren dieser polnische fahrer hat
ein halbes jahr für einen subunternehmer
gearbeitet rw nicht erkannt werden
ich bin meist um 10 uhr morgens
losgefahren und war nicht selten um 21
uhr abends zurück abgerechnet wurde dann
aber oft nur bis 18 uhr die überstunden
verfielen
das arbeitspensum sei kaum zu schaffen
irgendwann habe er nicht mehr gekonnt
erzählt er an einem tag ging es mir am
abend schlecht ich bin am folgetag zum
arzt der hat mich sofort krank
geschrieben ich war dehydriert ich habe
bei der arbeit angerufen gesagt dass ich
krank bin kurze zeit später rief der
chef zurück er sei auf dem weg zu mir
mit der kündigung
seitdem bekommt er kein geld mehr und
klagt nun gegen seine entlassung
unterstützt wird er dabei von der
beratungsstelle fähre mobilität hier
kennen sie viele solcher fälle
kurve fahren sind erkrankt worden geben
sie den krankenschein und darauf
reagierte arbeitgeber mit einer
kündigung bzw mit einem
aufhebungsvertrag
arbeitnehmer dazu zwingt zu
unterschreiben sie kämpfen gegen
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen bei
subunternehmern von amazon der konzern
trage eine mitverantwortung sagt tina
morgenroth ihre organisation unterstützt
fahrer bundesweit dieses system der
organisierten verantwortungslosigkeit
dass die arbeit an die subunternehmen
abgegeben wird dass die die menschen
ausbeuten und es amazon am ende versucht
natürlich mit einer reinen weste
darzustellen da zu stehen und zu sagen
bei uns läuft alles super die kundinnen
und kunden sind weiterhin könig der
preis dafür ist einfach dass es auf dem
rücken der beschäftigten ausgetragen
wird und das ist was was in der
öffentlichkeit bisher noch relativ kurz
kam immerhin weist die vorwürfe zurück
der konzern prüfe regelmäßig ob sich die
sub unternehmer an geltende gesetze
halten zitat
unsere lieferservice partner
verpflichten sich vertraglich die
geltenden gesetze insbesondere in
hinblick auf löhne sozialabgaben und
arbeitszeiten
einzuhalten
das ist eine antwort die wir leider
schon seit vielen jahren in diesem
system
hören und so lange man der auftraggeber
der an der spitze der pyramide sitzt
nicht wirklich in die unmittelbare
direkte verantwortung
und damit auch haftung für die zustände
in dieser lieferkette
genommen wird so lange wird sich an
dieser ich wasche mir die hände
reinhaltung auch nichts ändern der
online gigant wirkt umso unternehmen
lockt mit millionenumsätzen und einem
gewinnpotenzial von bis zu
140000 euro pro jahr auch michael
lennartz schick hat solche angebote
bekommen er besitzt ein kurier
unternehmen und hat schulungen bei
amazon besucht er sagt die versprechen
seien unrealistisch bei amazon regnet es
nicht es ist immer schön wetter die
zahlen sind so dargestellt als wenn
immer alles ganz ganz tolles und alles
ist in ordnung alles läuft reibungslos
hundertprozentig sauber und das ist
nicht so also ich weiß was es für
querschläge gibt es gab mal einen monat
da haben wir 18 reifen bezahlt da haben
uns die fahrer 18 reifen kaputt gefahren
kann man sowas kalkulieren das kann man
nicht kalkulieren
genauso wie unfälle es gibt monate
passiert nichts und im nächsten monat
kommt der fahrer drei mal rein und hat
irgendwo beim porsche cayenne in spiegel
abgefahren ein riskantes geschäft
bleiben dabei die einfachen fahrer auf
der strecke auf facebook machen viele
kuriere ihrem unmut luft viel ärger über
diese unternehmen
sie schulden mir drei monatsgehälter wer
es kann sollte sie meiden durch sie
wurde ich obdachlos
es gibt kein gehalt und sie lassen uns
zu tode schuften wer kann soll einen
bogen um sie machen
es sind drecks film ich scheue die
arbeit nicht aber was hier vor sich geht
nein danke darauf verzichte ich
fahrer die für ein bayerisches
subunternehmen gearbeitet haben
berichten uns dass die arbeit kaum zu
schaffen war am anfang waren es 100
stopps dann 200 dann 270 pakete in einer
schicht er es gab zeiten in denen die
pakete nicht auf der ladefläche sondern
auf dem beifahrersitz gestapelt werden
mussten weil es im laderaum keinen platz
mehr gab das war hart die männer kamen
aus ungarn nach bayern die autos seien
zum teil schrottreif gewesen erzählen
die fahrer und zeigen uns fotos bei
glatteis im winter hätten sie angst
gehabt zu fahren der zustand der autos
war sehr schlecht sie waren demoliert
die seitenspiegel abgebrochen und die
windschutzscheibe war gesprungen vor
allem die reifen die hatten kaum profil
ich musste natürlich damit fahren es war
lebensgefährlich
hier im bayrischen oberfläche ringen
hatte ihr arbeitgeber die oberland
logistik parcel service gmbh ihren sitz
der ehemalige geschäftsführer teilt uns
mit die wagen seien mietautos gewesen
mängel umgehend behoben worden der sub
unternehmer hatte den fahrern nicht nur
die autos sondern auch die unterkunft
vermittelt wir haben pro person 300 euro
monatlich für ein bett bezahlt wenn wir
vier leute waren dann also viermal 300
euro in den wohnungen war überall dreck
die küche war völlig nutzlos auf einem
einzigen herd mussten wir das wasser
erhitzen um uns zu waschen es gab nur
eine dusche die auch nur kaltes wasser
hatte oder gar kein wasser die badewanne
konnte nicht benutzt werden die dusche
war oft kaputt
sie zeigen uns lohnabrechnungen der
entdecken eine ganze reihe von abzügen
234 euro bearbeitungsgebühr blitzer 500
euro kfz schaden 300 euro miete manchmal
bleiben den fahrern nur wenige hundert
euro übrig einmal sind es nur rund 30
euro
ich konnte kein geld mehr nach hause
schicken und so ging eine beziehung in
die brüche es ist auch nicht billig von
münchen nach hause zu fahren ich habe
meine mietwohnung in ungarn kündigen
müssen und dann meine unterkunft hier in
deutschland so musste ich mehrere wochen
im auto schlafen ich hatte nicht mal
geld für essen
der ehemalige geschäftsführer weist die
vorwürfe zurück alle abzüge vom lohn
seien gerechtfertigt weder die firma
noch er selbst hätten daraus einen
finanziellen vorteil gezogen wir fragen
nach bei ermessen der konzern teilt uns
mit es habe keinen vertrag mit der
oberland logistik parcel service gmbh
gegeben sondern mit der oberland
logistik gmbh dieser vertrag sei im märz
außerordentlich gekündigt worden den
betroffenen fahrern sei hilfe angeboten
worden experten sagen der fehler liege
im system im jetzigen system kann amazon
die preise massiv drücken die anbieter
gegeneinander ausspielen die haben
überhaupt keine marktstärke und sind
gezwungen dann diesen enormen preisdruck
von amazon an die eigenen beschäftigten
weiter zu geben wir brauchen unbedingt
allgemeinverbindliche tarifstrukturen an
die sich diese oftmals vielen kleinen
unternehmen halten müssen die dann auch
in die preiskalkulation gegenüber amazon
natürlich eingang finden müssen bis vor
die wohnungstür lieferungen frei haus
dafür müssen die kuriere sorgen in der
korona krise wurde so viel online
bestellt wie nie zuvor bequem für die
kunden profitabel für amazon oft auf
kosten der fahrer